hi I'm Dr Joel wallik and what makes me
different is that I have degree in
agriculture I'm a veterinarian I have a
post-doctoral fellowship in comparative
pathology have done over 30,000
autopsies including 454 species of zoo
animals and human beings and I'm a
primary care physician as a naturopathic
physician since
1982 and I'm here to tell you that
you're going to hear something totally
different than you've ever heard before
when it comes to dealing with all the
major degenerative diseases all the
disease that the doctors have told you
are genetically transmitted all of the
birth effects you can prevent you'll be
glad you watch this
video what we're going to talk about is
how you can protect yourself how you can
protect your family the people you love
your church mates your neighbors and
your workmates this is something we need
to do the medical system has failed us
terribly and by doing Simple Things by
taking action you'll be able to do this
do not just sit here and say man that
was very entertaining and do not nothing
because then you will not be happy with
the outcome if you take action you'll be
very very happy with the
outcome well high blood pressure is a
very common disease it's certainly not
it is not genetically transmitted it's a
simple acquired disease um in most cases
it's caused by mineral deficiency and
you take the complete set of minerals
all 90 essential nutrients with a
complete Spectrum minerals and in most
cases the blood pressure will begin to
drop and blood pressure is one of those
nice things uh as your blood pressure
drops you can monitor yourself keep a
log uh keep track of your own blood
pressure and as the blood pressure drops
you can wean yourself off your
medications on occasion if people have
what we would call kidney failure you
can also cause high blood pressure
because the kidneys will release a
hormone called renin re n i n which
drives the blood pressure up trying to
drive more blood through the uh small
block blood vessels that result in
Highwood pressure so what do we do for
Highwood pressure we like to give the 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids and um in case
there's a circulation problem
contributing to this I like to throw in
the ultimate daily tablets and this will
support and promote healthy blood flow
through obstructed arteries and also
support healthy blood pressure don't
forget to give off don't forget to give
up the inflammatory foods fried foods
processed Meats uh things like Deli
slices sandwich meats sausage ham bacon
Boney have to give up gluten and oils no
olive oil no coconut oil no margin
mayonnaise CAD dressings cooking
oils arthritis is very common
degenerative disease it is certainly not
genetically transmitted in any way shape
or form i' say 90% of arthritis uh
begins as OST osteopenia osteoprosis
osteoarthritis degenerate arthritis and
really gets bad when you get to the bone
to bone arthritis point there is a
secondary type of arthritis called
rheumatoid arthritis which is an
infection with a bug called micoplasma
you can cure rheumatoid arthritis in two
weeks with a antibod called Minocycline
kills the bug very quickly and then you
do have the residual damage and the
residual damage of rheumat arthritis and
um the other forms of degenerative
arthritis I like to use the healthy Bone
and Joint pack all 90 essential
nutrients 160 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids there's a special emphasis
on what we call glucogel as part of the
healthy Bone and Joint pack and for an
average adult I like 15 a day five at
breakfast lunch and dinner and that's
designed to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone matrix and
Bone
itself
diabetes is a very interesting um
degenerative disease of the blood sugar
system it has nothing to do genetics it
is not genetically transmitted we've
known for 70 years that it's a simple
mineral deficiency disease and
regardless of age a type 2 diabetes
which makes up 98% of the diabetic
population I would get them on all 90
essential nutrients 60 essential
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids and
throw in what we call the secret sauce
sweeties and it has the the minerals
that are missing when you have uh type 2
diabetes uh you take the supplement
program one per 100 pounds per body
weight one bottle per month per 100
pounds of body weight that's three um a
day per 100 pounds of body weight and um
you take your fasting blood sugar each
morning before you medicate yourself and
as your blood sugar drops you reduce
your medication as you've been taught to
do by your doctor when your blood sugar
gets below 100 without medication for a
week in a row uh you're able to just
drop back to where your uh taking a
fasting blood sugar once or twice a week
to kind of keep tabs on it but it is not
a genetically transmitted disease easily
remedied obesity is not a genetically
transmitted disease and is certainly not
lack of exercise or eating too much it's
actually a simple mineral deficiency uh
you take the 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids three essential fatty acids and
like to throw in an accelerator uh we
call uh ASAP one dropper full under your
tongue 30 minutes before each meal if
you lean need if you need to lose more
than 50 lbs I would actually have you
take a dropper full on your tongue 30
minutes before each meal and a second
droper full on your tongue 15 minutes
before each meal and you'll begin to
lose up to half a pound to two l pounds
a day this is a simple mineral defici
disease has nothing to do with exercise
has nothing to do with eating too much
eating too much is a symptom of these
Minal
deficiencies well infertility is a very
simple problem I've gotten more women
pregnant than Solomon okay this very
simple disease this almost always
involves gluten intolerance so that the
mother cannot absorb nutrients it
requires an enormous amount of nutrients
just like going through puberty to get
pregnant and have a good pregnancy you
need to have all 90 essential nutrients
60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
and a gluten-free diet maximize
nutrition one of the things you have to
be concerned with are women who get
pregnant and then have miscarriages uh
early on and even in Middle pregnancy uh
this is not infertility because a woman
can get pregnant but they do have a
gluten intolerance and can't maintain
the pregnancy because they cannot absorb
nutrients it's imperative that all women
who have an infertility problem or have
a miscarriage problem must be on a
gluten-free
diet
ADD ADHD are certainly not caused by
vaccinations you can throw in autism
into the mix here ADD ADHD and autism
are all nutritional deficiencies
sometimes of the embryo the embryo uh
can be born as a little human being with
autism and ADD and ADHD to varying
degrees including um some variations on
um fetal alcohol syndrome fetal drug
syndrome and so forth it could be
Pharmaceuticals prescription drugs as as
well as street drugs and then of course
there are babies that are born perfectly
normal but then acquire ADD and ADHD and
autism because of
malnutrition um big um
uh a big thing you have to appreciate is
that our baby formulas including gerbal
and infam and simac have less than 20%
of the nutrients that are necessary for
a healthy growing person and we have to
supplement these babies before they're
conceived all through the pregnancy they
developed in from the moment they're
born you cannot depend solely on
Commercial formulas or natural
foods there's a whole battery of
diseases that afflict the brain we're
talking about depression Mac depression
bipolar disease
schizophrenia um and these diseases are
all what a psychologist or psychiatrist
would call um they would call them
chemical imbalances they would call them
chemical imbalances and of course they
are chemical imbalances not Prozac
imbalances but vitom mineral imbalances
so the first thing I like to do for
people with these types of emotional
problems that would include anxiety
attacks and panic attacks they have to
get off of all sugar all alcohol
absolutely no fried food no process
meets no oils no margins mayonnaise Sal
dress cooking oils absolutely no gluten
no wheat burner our oats and then they
must take the 90 essential nutrients for
160 minerals 16 bottomin 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
and make sure that they have healthy
prot protein and fats with every meal I
like them to eat eggs every
day the biggest cause of low energy and
fatigue is just lack of nutrition uh
that old adage you are what you eat is
absolutely positively not true you're
not what you eat you are what you absorb
and so when people have chronic fatigue
syndrome they have what people call
candidasis low energy just really not
with it I like them to get them on a
gluten-free diet no we brother ran o no
fried foods no processed Meats with
nitrates and nitrites no oils and then I
put them on the 90 cents of nutrients I
like the healthy heart and brain pack
for people with these emotional problems
throwing in the de-stress capsules three
of those twice a day per 100 pounds of
body weight
and things look
Rosy Sleep Disorders are a mix of
problems um insomnia is actually due to
Mineral deficiencies uh you take uh all
90 essential nutrients 60 minerals you
take 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential Amo acids 3 Essen fatty acids
and sleep comes easy you can take a
ounce of our Liquid ufx Plus before
bedtime and Ure a good night's sleep
sleep apnea is a normal procedure look
at a newborn baby they have sleep apnea
you look at a dog sleep you look at an
elephant sleep you look at a giraffe
sleep every vertebrate has sleep apne
it's an absolutely normal um Behavior Uh
medical system for financial purposes
has turned this into disease with cat
machines and surgeries it's absolutely
criminal uh there is no such thing as
people dying of sleep apnea or snoring
the only time you're going to die from
snoring and sleep apnea is when your
sleep partner shoots
you skin problems are always nutritional
deficiency diseases obviously there's in
certain infections but 99% of the time
uh things that don't respond to Medical
approaches uh are nutritional
deficiencies and invariably their
secondary nutritional deficiencies
meaning the person has usually gluten
intolerance they can't have wheat barley
R and oats if they do eat wheat barley
and R oats they get a contact enteritis
and this causes their intestines inflame
some dares will call it leaky gut
syndrome celiac disease appendicitis
diverticulitis eal V syndrome
inflammatory bow disease we're talking
about um uh things like Crohn's disease
all of these are due to gluten
intolerance well at that point you
cannot absorb nutrients particularly the
omega-3 essential fatty acids which
results in Asthma as well as things like
um dermatitis eczema
psoriasis rosacea on the face and your
intestines look like your skin does and
you have to get off of gluten all 90
essential nutrients you have to take the
um 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids three essential fatty acids
I would take extra of the omega-3
essential fatty acids the EFA pluses
take three of those twice a day per 100
pounds of body weight and eczema and
Asthma dermatitis and Asthma psoriasis
and asthma rosace asthma usually go away
in anywhere from 3 to four
months cancer is a self-inflicted
disease it is not genetic in any way
shape or form is self-inflicted from the
time um before you're conceived all
through the pregnancy you're developed
in from the moment you're born is caused
by a combination of free radicals and
lack of protection by lack of protection
I mean lack of bof flavenoids lack of
antioxidants protect you from free
radical damage trans fatty acids
heterocyclic amines and acrylamides if
you want to avoid cancer you must avoid
fried foods processed Meats with
nitrates and nitrites you must give up
oils including olive oil you must give
up coconut oil you must give up
margarine mayonnaise cell dresses
cooking oil and if Fe canned fish they
got to be packed in water mustard tomato
sauce not oil no gluten no wheat brother
IR oats in addition to taking the 90
essential nutrients appropriate for your
body weight 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essentio acids three essential fatty
acids I would like to throw in high
levels of antioxidants we have some
great ones of cell Shield
rtq um R for Resveratrol t for turmeric
Q for cortin then also like the
imortalium uh this is built on the Nobel
prize winning information of
2009 and um actually helps um maintain
the life and the health and the
stability of the telome which are the
endcaps and the chromosomes you do not
want to leave home without
it birth defs are a very worrisome
totally preventable set of events U
birth effects are actually caused by
malnutrition of the embryo there's not a
single now hear me there's not a single
genetically transmitted birth effect
that's all been a big myth that was H
running down the wrong Rat Hole okay and
um it's all caused by all birth effects
are caused by malnutrition of the embryo
and you can't name me a birth effect
that's caused by genetically transmitted
disease now doctors say that but it's
absolutely not true and so it's it's the
responsibility of the OBGYN it's a
responsibility of the grandmother the
mother uh to be long before she misses
her first two period to take all 90
essential nutrients to protect the
embryo remember you are not what you eat
you are what you absorb so you have to
maximize absorption no gluten no wheat
BR or fry and oats take the 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids three essential
fatty acids and you'll be able to reduce
the risk of birth effects almost zero
even if the whole family's been full of
them forever and that's because when
people get generationals disease like
diabetes or clef pellet or down syndrome
it is not genetically transmitted
because the mother cannot absorb
nutrients because she has a gluten
intolerance or they live in a place in
which these nutrients exist in very low
amounts Alzheimer disease is a physician
caused disease it did not exist 43 years
ago today it's the number four killer of
adults over the age of 65 it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease a big
study done by John's Hopkins came out in
2004 showed that they could actually
prevent alz disease and they control
double blind randomized study on 5,000
people over a 10-year period with a
special doet restricting certain foods
and supplementing with nutrients right
and uh in February of 2012 the FDA came
out and said uhoh give up Stanton drugs
because statin drugs the drugs that
lower cholesterol actually increase your
risk of Alzheimer disease and type 2
diabetes do not take statin drugs that's
because when you have Alzheimer disease
your brain loses the myin which is the
insulation materal
and milin is 100% cholesterol there are
four other
dementias bastor dementia chusov
syndrome Mor corov syndrome and um
Alzheimer disease and Alzheimer disease
Al also there is the uh dementia that's
caused by a vitamin B12 deficiency goes
along with pernicious anemia so uh all
90 essential nutrients 160 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids six eggs a day per
100 pounds of body weight poached also I
would throw in the de-stress capsules uh
three of those three times a day when a
person has dementia I take that many
just to prevent
dementia cardiovascular disease is not
genetically transmitted certainly it's
um it's uh one of those diseases that
are self-inflicted it's caused by free
radical damage to the heart it has
nothing to do with cholesterol there's
no heart disease that has anything to do
with cholesterol clogged arteries is not
due to cholesterol stroke is not due to
cholesterol cholesterol has nothing to
do with cardiovascular disease nothing
so what causes cardiovascular disease
well congestive heart failure is a
deficiency of a single vitam we've known
that since the
1700s and then there's cardiopathy heart
disease which causes sudden death in
athletes and people who do heavy
physical work people say oh they just
dropped dead of a heart attack that's
cardi mopy heart disease is due to a
deficiency of a single minerals selenium
I've actually done 1,700 autopsies on K
age of 10 in kishan China they actually
died of that disease very familiar with
it and then of course there is coronary
thrombosis which is caused by an omega-3
essential fatty acid deficiency or ratio
problem between Omega-3s sixes and nines
and then there's obstructive artery
disease which is due to inflammatory
foods fried foods process Meats oils and
gluten got to stay away from all the bad
stuff and of course you want to protect
yourself you take the 90 essential
nutrients I like the a healthy heart and
brain pack for this one 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids three
essential fatty acids
one healthy heart and brain pack per 100
lbs of body weight I also like to throw
in the extra de-stress capsules three of
those twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight and you're home
free low libido in both males and
females is a big problem and this is due
to lack of nutrition 6 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential Amo acids three
essential fatty acids and of course we
need to keep the card PR system
available and open we need to for both
males and females and we have to get the
hormones going so I like to have um six
eggs 68 eggs per 100 pounds of body
weight each day for both males and
females because testosterone estrogen
progesterone are all steroid hormones
95% of the weight of these hormones are
cholesterol you cannot be on a low
cholesterol diet you cannot be on a
cholesterol oring drugs and have a good
sex life um low tea and erectile
dysfunction
menopause is all due to a cholesterol
deficiency a physician inflicted problem
okay I like to come up with of course in
the old days we used to call it the stud
hor formula in the Philly pack today we
have what we call the healthy heart and
brain pack one per 100 lounds of body
weight it's going to give the testicles
the ovaries everything they need to make
the hormones they need to make in
addition to that for males I like to use
the the um selenium extra selenium I
also like to use extra Prost effect and
throw in GTO not the car but get turned
on great great drink and then for
females I like to use the woman's FX
15-year-old herbal blend uh called
woman's FX the liquid form 1 oce twice a
day per 100 pounds of body weight if
they prefer capsules balance FX three
twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight get turned
on now what we shared with you today is
the way to add 25 to 50 healthful years
to your life
you have to take the action to make it
happen this is something that is doable
there is over hundred billion dollar
worth of research involved in the
statements that have been given here
today only you though can make it happen
you have to take it and use it we can
save America together but we're going to
have to do it together because the
medical system has failed us terribly
only Dead Doctors Don't
Lie
for